Maybe we'll get started.
I'm Tom Gajewski from the University of Chicago.
I'll be hosting my colleagues, chairing this session,
where we're going to think about mechanisms of
efficacy versus failure of cancer immunotherapy and
trying to overcome that failure category. I'm a little bit hoarse.
Some of you might know we were playing music on Sunday night, and it got pretty
loud and so I apologize for the quality of my voice, but hopefully I'll
get through the talk. I won't be singing at least.
So,
I'm going to give some introductory comments since I'm first embedded in the
beginning of my talk, and then I'll get into the meat of
my talk. So just, these are my disclosures, none of which are
pertinent
here. And this is sort of the
basic context in which we're thinking about
a major category of immunotherapy resistance.
And that is this notion that, was surprising at first,
these findings were made 15 years ago, that
when we started to study the immunobiology of the tumor microenvironment in real
patient samples, we realized that a major subset of
patients had at baseline this smoldering immune response against their tumor.
And it's important to keep in mind the components of the immune
system that are present in those, what we call T cell inflamed tumors.
It includes CD8 T cells, CD8 positive T cells.
There are other T cells there as well.
It goes beyond alpha beta T cells. There are gamma delta T cells and K
cells.
And some of those CD8 T cells are tumor antigen specific,
not all of them. There are bystander T cells in those tumors as well.
It's not clear functionally if they're contributing anything
positively or negatively.
And
just probing the number of T cells in a tumor is not enough to
understand
the process that's happening. In some tumors, most of the T cells are
irrelevant T cells. There also are chemokines and
cytokines, chemokines that are responsible for recruiting
the CD8 T cells,
and other components.
These T cell inflamed tumors have dendritic cells, and the most important dendritic
cell subset are the BD3 lineage CDC1 cells.
And we've shown recently, and others have as well, that there are clusters of
those CD8 T cells and BD3 dendritic cells in these T cell inflamed
tumors, and that's a predictor of anti-PD-1 efficacy because
it's the dendritic cells that give a positive signal to the T cells once you
block PD-1, and then the T cells expand.
That's the accelerator when you remove your foot off the brake.
And these tumors also have a type I interferon gene signature.
The type I interferons are made by myeloid cells, by dendritic cells.
In mice, it's mostly dendritic cells.
It could be other myeloid cells in these tumors.
And mechanistically, you need the type I interferon signaling
to get the dendritic cells going to cross-present antigen
to the T cells. So these
key elements are in the T cell inflamed tumors and the non-T
cell inflamed tumors lack those elements.
And so when we think about how to correct
this defect, how do you overcome the
deficiencies in the non-T cell inflamed tumors?
A lot of the work has focused on putting things back.
Can you activate an innate immune pathway, with
TLR agonists, with
STING agonists, as we've done?
It turns out those interventions
have limited efficacy because they're not sufficient to make a
cold tumor hot. I think you need the right cells there as well.
For CpG, you need plasmacytoid dendritic cells.
For a STING agonist, we know you need CDC1 cells in the tumor for a STING
agonist to work pre-clinically.
So, putting things back is still ongoing.
There are more clever ways that are being pursued to get
the good stuff into
the non-T cell inflamed tumors. And then
another consideration is
that our anti-PD-1 responders
fall into the first category, right?
Beginning with reactivation of T cells that are
already in the tumor microenvironment.
Okay, so putting stuff back is ongoing, but that's only half
of the picture. These are just data to
support that
the efficacy of single agent anti-PD-1 is
enriched in patients who have this activated T cell gene signature
characterized by gamma interferon, gamma interferon-induced genes at baseline.
That's true beyond melanoma, where I work, but head and neck cancer,
gastric cancer, and others.
And so it means that the major subset of
tumors that are refractory to anti-PD-1
efficacy have the cold tumor phenotype.
I want to add that we're putting a review paper together about this
now that we're viewing the spontaneous anti-tumor
immunity when you see it like this,
really resembles autoimmunity. And so we're starting to think that
this is the exception, not the rule.
Some patients are more predisposed to make an autoimmune reaction
against their
tumor because of germline genetics, microbiome composition.
And so that viewing spontaneous anti-tumor immunity
through this lens of autoimmunity is useful for the way we're thinking about
the problem.
Okay, so those are the introductory comments.
You can reset my clock, although I won't go over.
To now talk aboutAre there bad things
present in the cold tumors?
And so, do we have to give good stuff back
or do we have to undo bad stuff, block bad stuff?
And so there are multiple studies, and we have in-house
data, and this is one from the literature,
that the macrophages are distinct in the T cell inflamed tumors
and non-T cell inflamed tumors. The T cell inflamed tumors have
inflammatory macrophages, so-called M1 type macrophages.
So these are here. You have chemokines like CXCL9 and
CXCL10, and they're contributing to recruitment
of the CD8 positive effector T cells that have CXCR3 on their
surface. The non-T cell inflamed tumors
have immune suppressive or pro-tumor macrophages.
And so in addition to trying to introduce, let's say,
dendritic cells and activate them with STING agonists and so on,
maybe it's going to be necessary to
change the phenotype or change the differentiation state of the
macrophages in the tumor microenvironment to be more supportive.
And, going back to that first cartoon,
what is present in non-T cell inflamed tumors, obviously, you have tumor cells,
you have
the vasculature, the neovasculature, you have fibroblasts, and you have
macrophages. You always have macrophages.
It's just that the macrophages are different.
So, through our work over the past several
years, looking at different dimensions of
mechanism that could explain lack of anti-PD-1 efficacy,
several of these stories have landed on an
opportunity to change macrophage phenotype, and this is what's getting us excited.
We used to think that all roads lead to beta-3 dendritic cells.
Now we're thinking for the resistant tumors, all roads are leading to these
suppressive M2-like macrophages.
So I'll tell you three vignettes,
short stories, if you will.
One about the microbiome regulation of anti-tumor immunity through
the gut microbial composition.
A target that's a myeloid target, that's called PKC delta, protein
kinase C delta,
and then a new regulatory protein on these
macrophages called GPNMB.
So just as a background, the
composition of the gut microbiome we showed in mouse models was important for the
degree of anti-PD-1 or PD-1 blockade efficacy.
And then this was extended to patients where we started
biobanking stool samples in melanoma patients who went on to
get anti-PD-1 based immunotherapy.
And just by sequencing, there were bacterial entities enriched in the patients who
went on to respond, and other bacterial entities enriched in
patients who did not respond.
I'll show in a minute how we think that this is causal in about
half of the patients.
And both of these are important. I won't show the data, but we think there are
immune-supportive bacteria, and then there are bacteria, we put them in, and we
lose the immune response against the tumor.
And obviously, Jen Margol's group and Laurent Siefogels group
found similar observations. Although the details of the bacteria aren't
the same in the different studies, the phenomenon
was supported.
So,
the next steps were to work on identifying the
bacteria, but then also mechanism.
And the way we were studying functionality was by
transferring
a sample from a patient into germ-free mice that didn't have their own microbiome
and then looking at anti-PD-1 efficacy.
But that doesn't give you enough mice to do experiments, all the kind of
studies that we want to do, tracking the cancer immunity cycle and
doing single-cell RNA-seq and so on.
You can't just do that with one set of mice.
We needed a stable,
let's say, colony of mice. So what we decided to do
is transfer stool from non-responder or
responder patients, prove the phenotype, and these are in separate isolator
cages in the gnotobiotic facility.
And then we bred the mice to maintain colonies of, let's say, responder
mice and non-responder mice, and that worked.
So this is an example. I've taken away the no
anti-PD-L1 group,
just for clarity. But this blue curve is from a
non-responder patient. These mice don't respond to
anti-PD-L1 at all.
And then the red curve is mice that got stool from a responder
patient, and they do respond. Then we breed the mice and the
next generation of pups. We haven't done any FMT
here. We're just letting the microbiome just naturally pass from the parents to
the offspring. And you can see the phenotype is retained
generationally. So now we can have cages of mice and do all kinds of experiments,
and it's been
a great model system also for identifying the bacteria, cloning them, and figuring
out mechanism through metabolomics.
And I want to emphasize one aspect of the
mechanism here for the theme of this talk, which
is once we had these sets of mice and we were mapping
out where's the defect in the immune response in the mice that
have the non-supportive microbiota from a
non-responder patient. The T cell priming in the draining lymph node was
similar. The initial expansion of T cells that you could find in the
circulation reflected in the spleen was similar, and the initial
trafficking of T cells into the tumor microenvironment was
similar. But then as the tumors grew a little bit and started
to separate,
when we did single-cell RNA sequencing, the big
shift was in the myeloid cells. And so
theMice that got responder microbiota had more inflammatory
macrophage gene signature, and then the granulocytes
also flipped so that the
non-responder microbiota mice had a transcriptional
signature of the granulocytes that looked more like myeloid-derived suppressor
cells. So it's an effect of the myeloid
cells that is dominating. And
recently,
Viera Madsen has
studied outside the tumor, because we're wondering, is this a system-wide effect?
And it is. So when you look at macrophage phenotype in
the spleen, for example, and she's done one
experiment in the bone marrow, the macrophages are different.
The myeloid differentiation seems to be different when a mouse has the
non-responder microbiota. So we think this is a dominant effect.
So in terms of microbiome interventions, there were two
studies published a few years ago now in "Science" showing that
it was possible to take anti-PD-1 failed melanoma patients,
do FMT either from a responder patient or
a healthy donor, and then repeat the anti-PD-1, and each of
these studies had a couple of responders, right?
So that's proof of concept that at least in some instances, a
microbiome intervention can be therapeutic and can
restore efficacy. Now, in one of these studies, there was RNA
sequencing done of patients' tumors before
and after treatment with FMT and before and after treatment with
anti-PD-1.
And
you can segregate these data, responder, non-responder.
And so based on the gene signature for the
macrophages in our mouse model,
the group went and reanalyzed these clinical data from the published study.
And you can see that in patients who went on to respond to FMT
plus anti-PD-1 as a rescue,
had the upregulated inflammatory macrophage gene signature sort of
correlating that
in the clinic like we found in the mice.
So I think this is a clinically relevant finding
that we need to explore more, and maybe this is going to be one way as
we're pursuing more precise microbiome
interventions. We'll be looking for a shift in macrophage
phenotype in those patients.
So the second vignette, it came from a very
different direction to try and understand mechanisms
of failure of anti-PD-1, and we entertained the hypothesis
that there were germline polymorphisms in immune regulatory genes that could
be teeing up patients to respond. Like I was
mentioning, we're starting to think
about spontaneous antitumor immunity in the clinic, kind of like autoimmunity.
And we know there are germline variants in immune regulatory genes that predispose
towards autoimmunity, so maybe there are some that predispose towards
antitumor immunity. And now we have a bunch of these identified and
some of them mechanistically studied.
And the first was
a hypomorphic allele of the protein kinase C delta
gene. And this got us excited when we found this
in clinical samples. So this variant was
correlated with an increased T cell infiltrate in the tumor microenvironment.
All right? This got us excited because germline
mutations in PKC delta are linked to
familial lupus,
so that patients who completely lack the PKC delta gene,
they all get spontaneous lupus. So it's the direction that we
want, right? We're looking for genes, when you lose function, they
predispose towards autoimmunity, and we're thinking about antitumor immunity like
autoimmunity.
And just as a reminder, the CTLA-4
pathway, before CTLA-4 was a target for ipilimumab,
it was identified as the second-most
frequently polymorphic gene associated with autoimmunity. Right?
So in a way, we've sort of pursued
targets that are connected to autoimmunity already in our cancer immunotherapy
field.
So we made a knockout mouse, conditional knockout mouse, and when you get rid of
PKC delta in the hematopoietic cells, you have
spontaneous tumor control. And this is T cell-dependent tumor
control.
But when we, again, we did single-cell RNA-seq of the immune cells in the tumor
microenvironment, PKC delta is not expressed in T cells.
You have this T cell-dependent effect of
markedly improved spontaneous tumor control.
But when we look, here are these violin plots, all of the
different cell lineages in the tumor microenvironment, it's all myeloid cells that
express PKC delta. There's a little bit in B cells, but
the rest is all myeloid cells. And when you now look at
differentially expressed genes in each of these subsets of cells in the tumor
microenvironment, the biggest difference of, let's say,
transcriptional phenotype is in macrophages and in neutrophils again.
And
here's an example where
the PKC delta knockout now has increased expression of
transcripts associated with inflammatory macrophages. All right?
We also conditionally deleted it from macrophages, and
we've done some experiments deleting preferentially in neutrophils,
and each has a phenotype.
So here, if we just get rid of it in macrophages, we have some
improved spontaneous tumor control.
And then now you can see that PD-1 blockade is much more efficacious with
a bunch of the mice having complete responses, just like the correlate
in the patient. And so now we have a target.
This is a kinase. So we should be able to develop small molecule
inhibitors. We have a big project going on with medicinal chemistry
to identify inhibitors that are selective
for PKC delta over other PKC family members.
We have partial selectivity so far. That's a work in progress.
But perhaps we can drug this target and shift the myeloid
phenotype in vivo and then improve
anti-PD-1 efficacy in that way.And
Kyle Cron, who did this work, took his
PKC delta knockout-like gene signature in the mice,
correlated it with a human gene signature, and he found that
patients whose tumors by bulk RNA-seq
had a gene signature that looked like that PKC delta knockout
gene signature were the ones that had disease control or
better with anti-PD-1, correlating it back to the patients.
All right. Third vignette. I'm going to take a sip of water for my hoarse
voice from Sunday night.
And this is
GPNMB, which is a little-studied
protein. We found this in a transcriptional
profiling study in mouse tumors
to be upregulated. And
when we started to look at different single-cell RNAseq
data sets from mouse and man, it turns out
that it's
expressed largely in macrophages as a dominant
cell expressing it. Here you can see myeloid cells.
This is a published study of breast cancer, triple-negative breast
cancer, responding or not to anti-PD-1.
And you can see GPNMB transcripts are in the myeloid compartment, and then it
turns out to be macrophages. And Ruxandra started studying this in
mice, and just a
control data set.
We don't think that in vitro bone marrow-derived M1-like and M2-like
cells reflect what's going on in real tumors.
But when she differentiates them to M2, these are the ones that have
GPNMB, and she showed this is a
STAT6-dependent transcription of this gene.
So we made a knockout mouse, and in a couple of different models.
Here this is our standard
B16-SIY model that has a model antigen.
And you can see, again, the knockout mice have a very
substantial spontaneous tumor control.
So this is a confirmed negative regulator of the antitumor
immune response by these experiments.
Because of the observation that in the clinical data set,
breast cancer myeloid cells express this gene, Ruxandra also has
done an orthotopic breast model, and you can see there's also
marked tumor control in this knockout.
I don't know if I have the data here, but that tumor control is T-cell dependent.
If you get rid of T-cells, you lose the effect.
So this isn't a direct, let's say, macrophage
cytotoxicity. It's indirect through T-cells.
So in the wild-type and knockout mouse then, we could do single-cell RNA sequencing
of the immune cells in the tumor microenvironment and see what's changed.
And what's very clear is that in the
knockout mice, you have upregulated transcripts in macrophages
associated with inflammatory macrophages. Right?
And what's interesting is,
in our different models, we get, let's say, five to eight
different macrophage subsets that we can identify by single-cell RNA
sequencing. And some of them have
defined properties that are published
to
correlate with immune suppression and pro-tumor growth.
And two of these are the SPP1
positive and C1QA positive. So it
turns out GPNMB is dominantly expressed in this SPP1 positive
macrophage subset. But when you look at differentially expressed genes, when you
knock it out, you also have changed transcriptional
signature in the C1QA positive subset.
And what happens is these normally M2-like
macrophages, if you will, now express
pro-inflammatory markers. So what's happened is the suppressive
macrophages have become inflammatory macrophages. Right?
We haven't brought in more inflammatory macrophages. This is a change of phenotype.
Oh, and this is the data showing if you get rid of T-cells, you lose the
split.
So now we're trying to figure out which macrophage subset--
Where do those SPP1 macrophages come from?
And are they bone marrow-derived macrophages, or are they
tissue-resident macrophages that have moved into the
tumor? And so we made a conditional knockout mouse
then, and
this is with Vav1-Cre that should delete in all the hematopoietic cells
within the limits of what you can do with tissue-specific Crees.
There's no phenotype.
So we get rid of GPNMB from all the hematopoietic cells, the tumor
growth is not improved in either model. All right?
So then we wondered, we did bone marrow chimeras with the wild type into knockout
and knockout into the wild type, and it turns out you get
a phenotype if the host is GPNMB knockout.
Right? If the bone marrow is GPNMB knockout, you don't get
this tumor growth control.
And so we wanted to see if it was still macrophage-related, and so now we
cross to Lysozyme M-Cre, and if we delete GPNMB from
macrophages, we have the tumor growth control phenotype.
And so we don't have all the data yet, but we're working with the notion that this
GPNMB pathway is
largely through, or at least a large component of it is
through tissue-resident macrophages that are there for tissue
homeostasis that enter the tumor microenvironment as the tumor's growing,
and that this is negatively regulating the antitumor immune
response.
I don't have the data here, but it turns out the T-cell
loop is part of the equation. So when we
get rid of GPNMB,
you have the anti-inflammatory macrophages become
inflammatory.But it's a two-step process.
You need to get rid of GPNNB, and you need gamma interferon from the T cells.
And then they work together to turn the anti-inflammatory
macrophages into inflammatory. I tried to argue that this
BATF3 T cell interaction is important in the tumor microenvironment,
and getting dendritic cells and activated dendritic cells in the tumor is
probably important. But that these suppressive-like macrophages
in non-T cell inflamed tumors could be dominant.
So that even if you get T cells in, maybe they wouldn't
function because they would glob on to the M2-like
macrophages. I don't like that term, but the suppressive
macrophages, and that they would become dysfunctional.
And then we have the microbiome interventions, PKC delta, and
GPNNB as
new
candidate targets to try and change this situation.
I tried to mention people's names as I went, but Viara, Jessica, and Yao Pang
are doing the microbiome work. Kyle Krohn did the PKC delta, and
Ruxandra Tornea, the GPNNB, who gave a great talk during the
meeting that was more thorough than what I presented.
Thanks, and I think there are a couple of minutes for questions.
Congratulations, Tom. As a T cell
person, I've come kicking to believe that macrophages are
important,
very much so. I actually have a question about your
preliminary introduction. Do myeloid engagers
reprogram the myeloid cells in the tumor microenvironment to
make them more M1-like?
Yeah. So define myeloid engager.
Well, my follow-up question would be, is there a favorite
version that you like? Like CLC5, CLC7.
Yeah. So, I don't know.
We pursued it from the angles I expressed, where we're trying to
understand correlates to response and resistance, and then see if we
can learn what to intervene on to tip the balance.
And so right now these are our favorite things, right?
So if-
So, for example, we know if we give a STING agonist...
And so we have this very dense immunotherapy-resistant
beta-catenin melanoma GEM model. Nothing works.
We put in a
model antigen,
also induced by Cre. Vaccination doesn't work, adoptive transfer
of, let's say, TCR T cells doesn't work, checkpoint blockade doesn't
work,
and unpublished, a STING agonist doesn't work.
So the macrophages are there, but at least that macrophage
intervention is not sufficient, right?
So if you're thinking instead of T cell engagers, macrophage engagers, would
there be a favorite-
I'm not calling them engagers. I think we're trying to tweak the
macrophages. I think maybe we can drug PKC delta
and have a shift towards inflammatory macrophages.
Maybe we can block GPNNB. We're working on the receptor.
This is a molecule that's been studied in different systems.
We've made conditional knockouts of candidate receptors with no phenotype,
so we have to go after the relevant receptor, yeah.
Thank you.
And maybe we could block that interaction. So these are our favorite things.
I'm
trying to think all of my favorite things.
Anyhow, I'm not going to start singing.
"These are a few of my favorite things," Mary Poppins.
I think Kim was over here.
This question will be a lot simpler.
It looks like maybe the PKC delta drug ability might be the
most translational into the clinic.
So, the obvious question is, will there be somehow a
better way to separate the immune-related toxicity of these
approaches from the
enhanced benefit anti-tumor effects?
If its loss causes lupus, it doesn't really sound like it.
Yeah. That's right. Well, same thing with
CTLA-4, right? Just hypomorphic alleles of CTLA-4 cause
autoimmunity. And I think the advantage of a small
molecule approach is
that you can stop the drug, right? And so if we
start to see autoimmunity or let's say immune-related adverse events, you
stop it and the drug will be cleared and the patient should recover more quickly
than with an antibody that's sticking around for three months.
So, anyway.
Thank you so much. It's a fantastic talk.
I personally was looking forward to you singing, but it's okay.
Next year.
ASCO.
Yeah. So my question is along the same lines of
polarization of myeloid populations
in tumor types that are particularly immune
cold.
Immune checkpoint blockade is often combined with chemotherapy, and
part of the rationale there being that chemotherapy can potentiate this
anti-tumoral immune response, turn the tumor more hot,
engage cytosolic DNA release and sensing, so on and so forth,
and part of that is certainly myeloid cell
repolarization. Any thought as
to how that might play a role into some of the results that
you're presenting here?
Yeah.
And could that potentially be, I guess, a wise strategy in this case?
Yeah, I guess I'm more attracted to, let's say,
interventions with greater precision than chemotherapy.
And,
what we're kind of pushing towards is to understand the proportion,
the best we can by these transcriptional profiles, of the tissue-resident
macrophages versus monocyte-derived macrophages in different cancers.
And some of the cancers that I think are really densely resistant
to checkpoint blockade are probably just
loaded with, and sort of protected by, the tissue
repair,
tissue-resident macrophages, which I think are harder-To manipulate, right?
Because they're there to protect the tissue
and
discourage inflammation. So my prediction is that,
let's say standard breast cancer, pancreatic cancer, colon
cancer, maybe prostate cancer. Larry's going to talk about, we'll see what
his extended story is going to be, are going to have more
tissue-resident macrophages that are harder to shift, I think.
But this GPNMB,
accidental discovery could be one way.
And I think we have to stop the questions, unless you have a quick one.
Because I'm chairing too, so I have to regulate myself.
So
GNPB has a functional role, but you think
SPP1, which is on the same macrophages, is more like a
marker and no functional role?
Oh, I don't know. We haven't studied the function of SPP1.
So that was a quick one. All right. So thank you, Dr.
Gajewski, for
an insightful talk. And the second speaker of
the session will be Daniel Pieper from the
Netherlands Cancer Institute, who's going to discuss more of a peripheral
blood-based discovery platform for response versus resistance.
Thank you, Tom.
Good morning.
As we've seen also at this conference, immunotherapy
has really shaped and improved the field.
But in spite of this success, we also see that many patients
still fail to respond durably.
And
that's why the focus of my lab is
on two major goals in cancer immunology.
First is that we want to address the mechanisms that drive
immunotherapy resistance. And secondly, we are interested
to identify and discover new targets that we can use to increase the
impact of immunotherapy.
So our view is then that in order to really
achieve a significant impact,
we need to be able to translate what I refer to as the cancer immune
dialogue. And by translation, I mean
the word in two senses, so both literally and
figuratively. Literally, because we really need to try and
understand how the tumor cells and immune cells communicate with one
another.
And figuratively,
we
want to use the understanding of those mechanisms to
translate these findings into new therapeutic
avenues.
So my lab asks three major questions.
One is what's the mechanism of tumor cell intrinsic resistance?
And once we have a better understanding, how can we break it?
That's one major problem of immunotherapy resistance.
Another one is T cell dysfunction.
And also here we ask the question, what's the cause of dysfunction, and
how can we overcome it? So I'm going to show you two little vignettes for both of
these questions. And the third question is more recent work from
my lab, where we really focus on the interface
between tumor cells and T cells and address how they communicate and whether we can
translate this into therapeutic opportunities.
So the first question was addressed by a range of people, David Thomas and Kwee
Kong and Martin, and what they did first is to establish a
standardized co-culture system where they made sure that CDA T cells and
tumor cells communicate, and that's being mediated
by a Mart1 specific TSR that's expressed in the T cell.
The corresponding antigen Mart1 is expressed in the tumor cell, presented by
HLA-A2. And when we culture the two cell types,
there's a match, there's tumor cell recognition, and if all goes well, the tumor
cell's eliminated. If we plug in the standardized system in a cell
line panel, we see a differential tumor sensitivity.
So this is one example of a cell line that's completely eliminated by these Mart1
specific T cells. But using the same standardized system,
here's a resistant cell line that is not killed at all.
That creates a really nice window of opportunity for doing
genetic screens where we can screen back and forth to
make or break resistance to T cell killing.
Here's just one example where we do a full genome knockout
screen in melanoma exposed to Mart1 specific T
cells, and then we look at the guide distribution in the tumor cells that
survive. And here we see three genes that are involved in antigen
presentation machinery, and they're positively selected.
That makes sense because if those genes are inactivated, these tumor cells stay
under the T cell radar.
From the translational point of view, it's more interesting to look at the
depleted site, where we have several guides, like
RNF31 and TRAF2 targeting guides,
that are depleted. In other words, if those genes are inactivated, the
tumor cells become much more sensitive to T cell killing.
It occurred to us that many of those genes map to the TNF signaling
pathway, which comes in two different arms.
On the left-hand side, you see a survival arm, and on the right-hand side, you see
a pro-death arm. And all the hits that we find in the screen map to the survival
arm.
And these two arms keep each other in check.
So there's a balance between those signals.
That's also seen here in a simple in vitro experiment where we use increasing
amounts of TNF
on these tumor cells, and you
can see that there's very little killing.
However, if we now inactivate one of the top hits of these screens,
TRAF2, there's a dramatic increase in the sensitization of these tumor
cells to T cell killing.
We did some biochemistry here. Now with T cell exposure, if you
have
this T cell pressure on the tumor cells, you can see the induction of
apoptosis if TRAF2 is inactivated.So
if you inactivate TREF2, and we have the same data for RNF31, we
really tip this balance from pro-survival to pro-death, and the effects are
sufficiently robust to see this also in tumor-bearing mice, as
in immune-proficient mouse models where the tumors are
established.
But if in the case of TREF2 knockout tumors, the tumors
regress and they stay away for a very long time, and the same is seen also for
RNF31. And the few tumors that escape here had lost the
RNF31 guide.
And this is completely reversible with anti-TNF.
So these two targets, TREF2 and RNF31, if we inactivate them in
tumor cells, we strongly
increase their sensitivity to T cell killing.
And therefore, they may serve as potential targets, for example, to be used in
combination with a checkpoint blocker.
Then one little vignette on the T cell dysfunction screens.
This is work by Astrid, Georgie, Champu, and Pierre.
It was about 10 man years of work.
And you can see that this picture was taken after the paper was accepted.
So, here we were looking at TCR stimulation,
which comes in different forms.
If it's really intense, it can cause fast-dependent
activation-induced T cell death or AICD.
If it comes in an acute form, it induces T cell cycle
arrest. And in a chronic stimulation setting, like we
see in tumors, it causes T cell exhaustion and dysfunction.
And the question we ask is, is there a single genetic program that relays
differential TCR stimulation to distinct dysfunction
outcomes? And the way we addressed this is, again,
using genome-wide screen
settings,
CRISPR knockout screens in primary mouse T cells that were exposed to
these three modes of TCR stimulation.
And the outcome was not that there's a single genetic
program, but instead, it turns out that there are distinct circuitries
that relay differential TCR stimulation to T cell
dysfunction.
We identified several genes,
for example, CTBP1, which was involved only in
dysfunction caused by chronic stimulation, but it didn't play a role in
any of the other stress conditions.
ICAM played a role in intense and acute TCR stimulation, but not in
chronic stimulation. And then DEP5 played a role in all
three dysfunction settings. If we inactivated DEP5 in
primary T cells, we saw a boost in global translation,
suppression of FAS expression and cell death, and a boost of T cell
activity and proliferation. And these effects were so robust that in
an adoptive cell transfer model, you can see that DEP5 knockout
T cells show significant tumor control.
All right, so moving on to the third vignette on the study on
the interface, where Sofia and Johanna, in
collaboration with Juan, Yolaine, Austin, and a whole range of other collaborators,
looked at how tumor cells interact with T cells.
They used the same standardized model that I already introduced for the
screens. In this case, the Mart1 TCR-expressing
T cells were labeled with a blue color, and the
tumor cells that expressed Mart1, which were recognized by the T cells,
were expressing a red color. And then again, we did a very simple
co-culture,
and looked with flow cytometry, at the
behavior of these cells. As expected, we see the input tumor
cell singlets here. We see the T cell singlets here, but we also
observed a double positive population suggestive of
doublets. Doublets, heterotypic doublets between tumor cells and T cells.
And we could validate this under the microscope.
So here we use a TCR antigen-matched T cell and
melanoma cells, and they form these heterotypic clusters when they're co-cultured
in a dish. Of course, the situation in the tumor microenvironment
is more complex because the majority, as Tom already mentioned,
the majority of T cells will not carry tumor-specific TCRs.
So we try to mimic this in this simplified reductionist
system, and we titrated in an increasing amount of non-specific T
cells. And then we did a competition experiment and asked,
who ends up in the doublets? Is that the non-specific T cell,
the specific one, or is it equally distributed?
So now if we increase
the percentages of non-specific TCR T cells to 99%,
we see a high enrichment of the specific matched
TCR T cells in the doublets. In other words, these
TCR-matched T cells out-compete non-specific T cells to form these
heterotypic clusters with tumor cells.
And this observation triggered our imagination.
And we hypothesized that perhaps these heterotypic clusters can be
used to capture tumor-reactive T cells straight from cancer
specimens.
Why is that relevant? Well, as already mentioned by Tom,
tumor-reactive T cells are underrepresented in the tumor microenvironment.
Therefore, it's been a challenge to identify and isolate those tumor-reactive T
cells from clinical samples. And with around
20% of complete responders in melanoma TIL
therapy trials, there is still ample space for
improving the benefit of TIL therapy.
So we set out to check a series of boxes to test
this hypothesis. The first thing, of course, was to ask
the question: Can we identify those T cell clusters in clinical samples?
So we built a pipeline. We collaborated with Rinan Van Hauw, John Hanna,
and others. And we received tumor digests.
We received a melanoma lymph node metastasis, and we made a mild
tumor digest.We ran some flow cytometry
analysis and looked for singlets and clusters.
And this is a typical plot that we got.
Here we see tumor cell singlets, large population, T
cell singlets, and indeed, we see this double positive population on the top
right corner suggestive of T cell tumor clusters.
Since we got these samples from lymph node metastasis, we also looked for T cell
APC doublets. And again, we see the presence of these
double positive cells. Small percentages,
but to give you some numbers, the CD8 T cell clusters comprise
about 1.4% of all
cells in these tumor samples,
and of the total CD8 T cells,
we see that about 12% is in clusters.
And we see this in all out of 21 patients that we've analyzed.
So we see these heterotypic clusters between CD8 T cells and
tumor cells, and CD8 T cells and APCs.
We can identify them and isolate them from clinical samples,
but we're still not completely
sure whether we're not looking at an artifact.
So we wanted to have some visual confirmation.
We did two approaches. One is multiplex immunohistochemistry,
and here you see some niches where the T
cells in blue, tumor cells in red, and APCs in yellow are really
residing in each other's vicinity, but that's still
not definitive evidence.
So then we made use of image stream flow imaging, which is like a
flow cytometer, but for every cell that passes the laser, it makes a nice picture.
So here in the bright field, we look at a large cell and a small cell.
The large cell
lights up with a tumor marker, the small cell with a CD8
marker. And in the merge, you can see that they're nicely conjugated.
One row lower is one of our favorite images.
It's one APC binding simultaneously to two CD8 T cells.
And here you see these structures that are highly reminiscent of an
immunological synapse, which suggests that this is in functional
interaction. We also see larger clusters, one tumor cell,
two CD8 T cells, and one APC, and that's why we refer to this as
clusters and no longer as doublets.
So then we asked, can we discover new biology of these
clusters, and are there any therapeutic opportunities?
So we built this pipeline where we now separate the singlets
from the clusters a-and perform a single-cell RNA-TCR
sequencing.
In the UMAPs, we see these three cell types, tumor cells, T cells,
APCs. The T cells come in 14 different cell
states, exactly as you would expect it, and in agreement with literature.
But now we can ask an interesting question, and that is, are the
reactive cell states equally distributed over T cell singlets and clusters?
And the answer is, they're not equally distributed because there is a strong
enrichment specifically of exhausted and proliferative cell states in
the clusters in comparison with T cell singlets.
We also looked at T cell reactivity gene signatures.
If you look at the top right, all these light blue bars
represent individual single T cells, and you can see that they're highly
reactive for a viral antigen specificity signature,
suggesting that these singlets are bystander T cells in the
tumor microenvironment.
In contrast, if you move to the left with the green and the purple bars for T
cells from APC and tumor clusters, we can see that those
clusters are highly enriched for tumor antigen specificity.
We also looked by single-cell sequencing for the TCR repertoire,
and we see that there's an increase in clonal TCRs specifically in the
clusters, and that suggests that those T cells have undergone selective
expansion and are active against the tumors in the tumor microenvironment.
But then, of course, the $64,000 question, are these T
cells from clusters better killers?
So we now expanded the pipeline once again and now include
one step, which we call rep for rapid expansion, which is very
similar to what John Hanna and others use for TIL therapy of
patients. So after the physical separations of singlets
from clusters, we individually
expand those T cell populations, and then they're ready for some
business
essays to look at their tumor killing capacity.
Here, if you look at the cytokine production, we already get a little hint
because the T cells
from clusters express more TNF, more interferon gamma.
But then the real killing assay on autologous tumor assays show that the
singlets show very little activity, and the T cells from
APC
in green and tumor clusters in purple show much
more killing activity. And we see this in all out of 11 patients that
we've looked at,
albeit to different degrees.
On average, we see a ninefold increase in melanoma killing capacity
by T cells from clusters in 11 patients.
We also reproduce this in mice with PDXs in an autologous
model with adoptive cell transfer.
This is in collaboration with Jonas Nilsson,
where we see that T cells from clusters infiltrate into the tumor much
better
than single T cells. They're more activated, and there's much more
expression of PD-L1 in the tumor microenvironment, suggesting
that there's a lot of interferon gamma being secreted by those T cells.
And this correlates with better killing capacity if you do adoptive cell
transfer with T cells from clusters where the tumor
APC clusters relative to single T cells, which do not
show a lot of killing activity here.
So we can identify, isolate, and visually confirm these
clusters. They're associated with T cells that have different types and
different cell states. I didn't have time to show you the data,
butWith the TCR sequencing data, we have T
cells
carrying identical TCRs, and they can bind either to an
APC or to a tumor cell, and we can show
that the TCRs,
when the T cells are bound to APCs, are more exhausted.
That those T cells are more exhausted than when they're bound to tumor cells.
It also allows us to ask new questions, of course.
So why are we the first to report this?
We're certainly not the first one to observe this, but the
immunologists among you
will be aware that those clusters are
commonly seen on flow cytometry plots, but they're typically gated out
for single-cell analysis.
And our results suggest that if you discard those populations, you
throw away a lot of biological information and perhaps indeed
even therapeutic potential, because what we see is that these
clusters are enriched for exhausted and proliferative T cells.
They're tumor reactive, they produce more cytokines, the TCRs are clonally expanded
and are much better killers in vitro and in vivo.
So what we're interested to do now is to use this
property of enriching
for reactive T cells in clusters to build
in a module in standard TIL therapy where there is no
purification of reactive T cells.
In this case, we try to purify the clusters and use
only those tumor-reactive T cells to make a TIL product.
We think that there's also an opportunity to identify the
TCRs from those clusters, and that's a very exciting
opportunity that we're currently actively pursuing.
So putting this into a context of this session, turning
cold tumors hot,
I'd like to draw your attention to step five of the cancer immunity cycle, which is
the infiltration of T cells into the tumors, which in not all cases
is successful because many tumors are immune excluded, as Tom already mentioned.
So there are T cells around, perhaps even some tumor-reactive T cells,
but they're spatially separated from the tumor cells and this hampers the immune
response.
We think it's interesting to investigate whether the T cells
that are at the tumor margin, whether they still engage with activated APCs
that present tumor antigens,
whether they form stable heterotypic clusters, and whether this would
enable isolation of tumor-reactive T cells, even few
tumor-reactive T cells that surround these cold tumors.
That remains to be determined.
In the final two minutes, I want to show some unpublished data
by Zoe and Adrian, who are really excited about this data on the
clusters and asked whether we can use these clusters
also to address the mechanism of T cell
tumor interactions in more detail.
So they used this cluster assay, as I just mentioned, and they also
developed an independent one based on proximity labeling, where
a turbo ID, which is a biotinylation enzyme, is expressed on the tumor cell
surface, and it labels neighboring proteins on the
interacting T cells,
which looks like this in the TCR matched system.
You see a nice lipstick mark that's left by the tumor cell after
it has kissed the T cell.
And in the tumor clusters, we see the plus, as I just mentioned.
So they integrated these two independent models with genetic
screening genome-wide in primary T cells, so they looked in the
proximity labeling setting for the top and bottom labeled cells,
and in the cluster assay they looked for singlets and clusters.
Then we got two pleasant surprises.
The first surprise is that although these assays were completely independent,
the top enriched hits in the screens were
identical. And MGT2 is one of those top hits.
What's the function of MGT2? It plays a role in a
complex N-glycan pathway. It sits over here.
And the second positive surprise was that in the
screens, we've identified 26 out of 38
enzymes from this entire pathway, which is essentially all the
rate-limiting enzymes in this signaling pathway.
We did a lot of mechanistic stuff, which I have to skip here because of lack of
time. If you do an in vitro killing assay,
and we use MGT to knock out T cells, you can see there's much better killing.
We also see that in vivo, there's more tumor control.
So if we perturb N-glycan biosynthesis, we see an enhancement
of specific T cell tumor cell interactions, and MGT2 is
one of the top hits.
And if we knock out MGT2 in T cells, we see better tumor killing in vitro and in
vivo.
So concluding this presentation, I've told
you
about how we use genetic screens to break tumor
intrinsic resistance and to have a better mechanistic
understanding about the pathways.
We identified several hits, including TREF2 and RNA 31, and a
couple of years ago, we set up a startup company to develop
inhibitors targeting those proteins.
On the T cell dysfunction side, I told you about a few
genes whose inactivation
prevents T cell dysfunction, overcomes it, like DEP5 and
MGT2. And
lastly, I told you about the mechanism of
functional interaction between tumor cells and T cells and how we can use
that to perhaps improve TIL therapy.
I want to thank my team. As you can see, they have so much
energy that they glow in the dark.
And also, many of our collaborators.
I've mentioned the most important ones, and our sponsors, and of course, the
patients, and you for your attention. Thank you.
Thanks, Daniel,
for that amazing talk. There are only about two minutes left for
questions, and there's one online, and it's
related to how I introduced you, too, because maybe I misremembered.
The question is, can you find those clusters in the peripheral blood?
And maybe I was just misremembering your work.
We've just started to look at it. We see the clusters
in all out of five different tumor types that we've looked at,
including
colon cancer, lung cancer,
sarcoma, endometrial cancer. And we've just started to
look in blood, and it is a bit too early
to tell you, but I'm quite happy
with the preliminary data. But this is very early days.
I
would imagine that in situations where there are circulating tumor cells detected,
it might be possible to detect-
That's exactly
... a few CD8 T-cells bound to some of them.
Yes.
Question here.
Thank you very much. Super interesting.
I was wondering if, in your system, you can also use
this doublet formation to distinguish the
parameters of the tumor cells that make them able to interact with T-cells
or not.
Yeah.
And if you track immunovisions like that?
Excellent question. So we've looked at different T-cell
states and their distribution in clusters and singles.
You can also do this with APCs or tumor cells.
And indeed, we see that not every tumor cell similarly binds to those
T-cells. For melanoma, we see an enrichment of the
tumor cells that have hypoxia signaling signatures
and MHC high signatures. Of course, the interesting question is, is
that a cause or a consequence? And we're looking into that.
Cool. Thank you.
Could we go to the left of us?
Thank you, Dr. Pieper, for the excellent presentation. I'm Kamal from Merck.
My question is, have you checked for overlap of
the TCR receptors between the individual T-cells you saw
versus the APC cluster versus the tumor-interacting clusters?
That's one question. Second question is,
have you tried to correlate the overlap of the TCR
frequency in the tumor? I understand this analysis was done in the
lymph node, TCRs, right? So have you tried to correlate that to the existence of
these TCRs in the tumor?
With the tumor-
How it correlates to response.
The tumor samples that we've analyzed,
most of them were lymph node metastases, and that's probably why also
APCs are highly represented. And back to your first
question, we're currently sequencing the TCRs and looking at the
distribution between single
T-cells and T-cells in clusters. It's too early to give you the details,
but it looks quite interesting.
Thank you.
One more question on this side.
Okay.
Great job. Really, really nice. You show in the beginning that some tumor
cells are resistant to cell death by engaging with T-cells.
So from the cluster work, when you find them together in the
patient, does the tumor cells ever resistant to that
contact too?
It's a very good question, and I just mentioned how we characterize the tumor cells
that specifically bind to these T-cells.
Of course, it's important to be aware that we're making a
snapshot, right? So we're looking at one
situation in time, one moment. At that moment,
most of the T-cells are singlet and some are in clusters.
If you would have taken the sample one day earlier or maybe 15 minutes
later, the distribution may have been a little bit different.
So we're not saying that all T-cell singlets
are the wrong T-cells, or
that they are not recognizing tumors at all.
What we do see and claim is that the
T-cells that are in clusters are very strongly enriched for tumor
reactivity. But it's a snapshot, and it's very
well possible that a low frequency of the single
T-cells also carries the right TCRs, and that's exactly what
we're looking at right now.
Great. Thank you.
Thank you.
Thanks again, Daniel.
So the third presentation this morning is from Larry
Fong, who's going to, I believe, talk to us about myeloid
cells in prostate cancer.
All right. Terrific. Well, I wanted to thank the organizers for
the opportunity to present.
And I am going to talk about myeloid-mediated immune suppression with an
emphasis on prostate cancer. But,
I think we're actually finding these cell types in other types of cancers.
And so I'll touch upon that briefly at the end. These are my disclosures.
And so, as we think about this session, hot versus cold, you could
think about it, also as well with regards to checkpoint inhibition,
into binning cancers into the sensitive
tumors to anti-PD-1 versus those that are refractory.
And so I'm going to focus on the refractory side and, in this
case, focus in prostate cancer. And just to
drive this point home about the refractoriness of prostate cancers, we now
have eight phase III clinical trials with different checkpoint
inhibitors that failed to show any survival advantage.
And so this is one of the clinical trials that looks at
atezolizumab.
Those patients receiving that drug are in the blue
curve, and you could argue that there's no difference, but you could also argue
that perhaps these patients receiving atezolizumab actually are doing a little bit
worse.
And so, when we think about immunotherapy and prostate cancer,
just to remind folks, there's actually an FDA-approved
immunotherapy for prostate cancer, and this is something I had worked on when
I was a postdoc a long time ago. But
this is basically an autologous cellular immunotherapy
that is loaded with prostatic acid phosphatase as
the antigen. And this was at a time when dendritic cell
vaccines were very much at the fore.
And in a couple of randomized clinical trials, it actually
showed about a four-month overall survival advantage.
And so for that, this was FDA approved.
But there was a lot of
challenges in terms of adopting this therapy because the patients who receive these
treatments don't have objective clinical responses.Their
tumors don't shrink, their PSAs don't go down.
And so this has always been, even though this is still a therapy we
can prescribe, it's not really used very much.
Now, when we actually studied this treatment, we showed that it actually
functions as a vaccine, so it induces these immune clonotypes that
are below the threshold of detection at baseline.
They circulate in the blood at high frequency.
The T cells, about a third of them T cell clones end up in the
tissues. But one of the things that we found was if you look at these patients
treated with sipuleucel-T, in this case, this is prior to
surgery, so this is a neoadjuvant trial.
We can actually see recruitment of the T cells into the tumor
microenvironment in those patients who are
treated. But down on the bottom here,
when you look in the tissues, these T cells are actually hung up in what we
called at the time the interface, so the invasive
margin that borders tumors from normal tissues.
And so this is what we now call an excluded phenotype.
So this vaccine was inducing T cells, but for whatever reason, they're
not able to actually migrate into the tumor centers.
And so we really wanted to understand the mechanisms of resistance
in the context of prostate cancer.
And so, one of the approaches that we took was actually
studying
biopsy tissues from patients
with different states of prostate cancer.
So localized disease, metastatic
hormone-sensitive disease. And then when you treat prostate cancer
with hormonal therapy, essentially ablating androgens,
patients typically progress to castration-resistant disease.
And this is the lethal form of prostate cancer.
And we subjected this to multi-omics single cell, and you can
identify the different cell types within these biopsies.
And we focused on the myeloid compartment, and I want to highlight, this
work was led by Aram and Zheng Hua.
And Aram actually just presented at this meeting with a
subsequent story that I'll
highlight. Now, when we think about the myeloid
compartment, Tom discussed these classifiers
of M1 and M2. When you actually look at the myeloid
compartment with single-cell methodologies, you can
see that there's actually considerably higher level of
heterogeneity, where we can actually identify discrete populations that
can be identified based upon specific genes that stand
out. And one that stood out to us was actually these
SPP1-high tumor-associated macrophages, or
TAMs. And you can see as prostate cancer progresses
along the continuum within the TME, the abundance of these myeloid
cells actually go up. And so this is actually the quantitation of that, where you
can see this increase in frequency.
But the other thing that I wanted to highlight was that these can represent
about 20% of the myeloid compartment within prostate cancer.
And then the other component is you can see there's actually a fairly broad
distribution in prostate cancer.
Now, oftentimes, when we think about myeloid cells,
we can think about their immunosuppressive capacity, and so we
can apply gene signatures for that.
And you can see that a few of these different populations have
immunosuppressive gene signatures.
Another way of identifying myeloid cells has
been TREM2. And so if you look at that, you can see that actually quite a
few different myeloid populations actually
overexpress TREM2. SPP1 myeloid cells have TREM2, but they're
not the highest expressers of that.
And so I think a lot of thinking about the myeloid compartment is whether you're a
lumper or a splitter in terms of how you want to classify.
If we actually look at this immunosuppression
signature, you can see not only are the SPP1 high
TAMs elevated in the suppression signature, there are actually other
populations that could also be contributing to
immunosuppression. But we wanted to drill down on these SPP1 TAMs and
actually test functionally whether they're suppressive.
Now, SPP1 is the gene that encodes for
osteopontin, and this protein is actually expressed
across multiple cell types, including multiple myeloid
populations as well as other stromal components.
And it's already known to play critical roles in bone remodeling as well as
wound healing and metastasis. We're not going to talk about SPP1
functionally in this presentation.
We're just using it as a marker for myeloid population.
And so what we wanted to do to test these functionally was actually to bring this
back into a mouse model. And so we utilized a mouse that
expresses GFP
with SPP1. We can actually
treat these mice with this mouse tumor with hormonal
therapy. You can see the tumors initially respond, and then they go on to
progress, not unlike castration-resistant disease.
And what we found is that the myeloid compartment actually, to a certain extent,
recapitulated the myeloid compartment within our patients.
And so we went ahead to study these.
And with these SPP1 GFP mice, what that allowed us to do was
basically be able to sort out these myeloid cells to
test them functionally. And what we found was that these
myeloid cells do indeed suppress in vitro, whether you look
in a proliferation assay or a cytokine production assay.
And then if you actually looked with regards to in vivo
immunosuppression, if you actually, in this mouse model, treat the
mice with combination checkpoint inhibition, you can see with the red curve that
there's actually some clinical activity.
But if you adoptively transfer in more of these SPP1 high TAMs, you
basically negate that efficacy. And this is just
looking with regards to exhaustion, where you can actually
see with checkpoint inhibition you reduce T cell exhaustion, but when you give more
of these SPP1 high TAMs, you actually, again,
negate that phenotype. Now, as we think about ways that these myeloid
cells can suppress, we looked at the different
molecular pathways that are operative in these TAMs, and one of them that stood out
to us is the hypoxia pathwayAnd we know in the context of
hypoxia, you get induction of many different mechanisms,
but one of them is actually the induction of these
ectoenzymes, CD39 and CD73, that
catabolize extracellular ATP, which is
released in cell death. That's actually immunostimulatory
to extracellular free adenosine, which we know is
potently immunosuppressive. And we can see that these SPP1 high
TAMs actually express high levels of CD73.
And in fact, we can actually detect these SPP1 high TAMs
producing adenosine into the culture supernatants.
So then, the question was, now that we identified this pathway, can we actually
block it therapeutically? And the answer to that is yes.
In this case, we looked at an adenosine A2A receptor
antagonist, zafirlukast.
And you can see in this case, a checkpoint inhibition just with
anti-PD-1 alone, really not doing very much.
But if you use this A2A receptor antagonist, you can actually see some
clinical efficacy, but the two together actually work better.
And you actually induce many more of these polyfunctional T cells in this
context. So then the final component of this initial
half of the talk is, does this actually have any consequence in
patients? And so I introduced to you at the beginning atezolizumab in that
phase three trial showing no efficacy.
In this case, we tested it either
with zafirlukast in combination or zafirlukast as a
monotherapy. And what we found is we can now see clinical
responses in about
20% of our patients with castration-resistant disease.
And this is just an example of one of the clinical responses that we
saw. But when we actually looked at the pretreatment
biopsies from these patients, one of the things we found was that these
responders at baseline had really high levels of these
SPP1 TAMs, whereas the non-responders did
not. And so what we would argue is that for
those subset of patients that have a lot of these SPP1 high
TAMs, perhaps blocking the adenosine pathway
could be a therapeutic approach. But then how do we think about these
other patients that don't have these SPP1 TAMs?
So,
are there other mechanisms that we could think about that elicit this
immunotherapeutic resistance?
And so, what we've since done, and again, this is
data that Aram just presented yesterday,
was expand our assessment of biopsies
in the castration-resistant disease setting to include
multiple sites of metastasis so that we could dive into this
further. And you can see with regards to the myeloid cell
populations, if you look at the soft tissues such as
prostate or even in liver biopsies, you can see the myeloid
compositions that we talked about a little earlier.
But if you look in bone, you actually don't see very many of these
myeloid cells that we've been focusing on.
Instead, you see a predominance of neutrophils.
And so if we look here in terms of the quantitation of this, I'm
sorry some of this got blocked out, but essentially what this shows is a
quantitation where there are really high levels of neutrophils
within the bone,
and really a low representation of these myeloid cells that we've been focused
on. And again, Aram has presented that at this
meeting. And so when we look at these neutrophils and
drill down on them, we can actually use naming conventions that are
already in the literature. And what we also did was
have patients who are tumor-free, so these are patients who are
undergoing hip replacement surgery, where we could actually get
their bone and
harvest cells from those. And you can see with regards
to a particular myeloid population, these
IL1 beta high mature neutrophils are
actually at increased abundance within the bone
metastasis, and this is much higher than we see in bone
that's not involved with cancer. And we can actually show that these
neutrophils are indeed present within the tumor microenvironment
by tissue staining.
So now applying that immunosuppression signature that we talked about,
we can actually see not only are these neutrophils
more abundant within the tumor microenvironment, they actually express
a higher level of this immune suppression
gene signature. And so you can see the tumor cells are
reprogramming these myeloid cells as well, hearkening
back to Tom's
presentation. And so what we wanted to do, again, was
transition this into a mouse model of osseous
metastasis. In this case, a tibial bone injection model.
We inject these mice, we treat them with hormonal therapy, the
tumors initially regress, and then they progress, and we again look by
single cell. And again, the neutrophil compartment to a certain extent also
recapitulates in these mouse models.
And we can see that these mature IL1 beta high
neutrophils actually are also high in the suppressive signature.
Now, with the single-cell data, we can actually nominate
surface markers that we could actually isolate these cells by.
And so two of these are CD62L and
CXCR2. And so we can actually use
FACS to sort these out and perform functional assays in
vitro, again, a proliferation assay as well as cytokine production,
and we can show that these neutrophils are functionally
immunosuppressive in vitro. What about in vivo?
So in this case, again, we treat the mice with combination checkpoint
inhibition. We can see
a slowing of the tumor growth. And if we actually adoptively transfer in more of
these neutrophils, we basically negate that
efficacy.Now, the other component is,
I mentioned to you they express these
CXCR2, which is a chemokine
receptor. And
one of the questions would be, if we actually targeted this chemokine receptor, can
we actually impact efficacy in this context
by preventing their migration into the metastatic
site? And so in this case, what we did was treat with combination checkpoint
inhibition.
You can see in this case, the blue curve, and actually if we
use a small molecule inhibitor of CXCR1 and
2, you can see enhancement of that anti-tumor
response.
Now, what about
mediators of immunosuppression?
And so
one of the signatures of these
myeloid cells is actually IL-1beta expression.
And I'm sorry this title got cut off, but one of the things
that we did do is actually look in vitro whether
IL-1beta actually is important
in mediating this immunosuppression.
And if we use antibodies against IL-1beta receptor, you can see
we actually
significantly reduce the amount of suppression that's here.
And if we look in vivo, we again can
rescue mice or improve their efficacy with regards to
checkpoint inhibition. So the conclusions for my talk,
myeloid-mediated mechanisms of resistance actually can differ
by disease context. And so, I initially
presented with regards to disease progression in prostate cancer.
We can actually see changes in the myeloid compartment and increases
in these SPP1 myeloid cells as tumors progress.
But we can also think about sites of metastasis actually having
distinct myeloid compositions.
SPP1high TAMs, we believe really
contribute to this immunosuppression in primary prostate
cancer as well as soft tissue metastasis.
But if we actually look at bone metastasis, we think that these
IL-1beta
high mature neutrophils are mediating in the immune suppression.
And so as we think about a disease like prostate cancer, where about
70% of our patients have bone metastasis when
they have
bony metastatic disease, we'd really need to think holistically
in terms of how we approach those patients.
And so,
with that, I'll close and actually highlight the
folks that
really led the efforts, Erim and Zhenghua.
But this really took a village and members of our lab, both at the Fred
Hutch as well as at UCSF, where we
moved from a couple of years ago, but also acknowledging the
clinical group with whom we performed these studies with.
I also just want to acknowledge our funding, as well as the patients and
families that motivate us to do what we do.
And with that, I'll close and take any questions. Thank you.
Thanks so much, Larry, for a stimulating talk. We have time for some questions.
I was curious, so the chemokine receptor inhibition, Larry, is that
something you're planning to try and move forward into the clinic with patients
with bone metastases?
Yeah, that's something we'd love to move forward.
The company does have a clinical
trial in prostate cancer because these chemokine
receptors may actually be relevant also with regards to tumor intrinsic
mechanisms.
But we'd love to actually test this in the context of
immunotherapy as well. Yeah.
Yeah. Awesome. Here on the right.
Yes. Thank you for an excellent presentation.
I was wondering about this
Sipuleucel-T.
You said they were excluded, but do we know whether they're
exactly where they need to be to prevent metastasis?
Was there a correlation between the outcome?
Yeah. Well, I think we do see
modest improvement in overall survival.
I would argue that excluded phenotype
probably
reduces the potential clinical
efficacy that we could see with Sipuleucel-T.
So if we could actually negate that exclusionary
phenotype, we'd actually see potentially better responses.
But that's something that
we'd need to test in many ways clinically, and that therapy
is now
many years old. And so I think doing those studies will be a bit
challenging, but that's a great question.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Nina, over here on our left.
Yeah. Great talk, Larry. I had a question about whether
you looked at IL-6 in the bony mets
model.
Yeah. We have not looked at IL-6. That's on our list
of to-dos, but I think that's a really great
point, and there could be a contribution by IL-6. Yeah.
Yeah. Thank you.
Okay.
Hi, and thanks for the great talk. So,
the prostate cancer CRPC shows different epigenetic
subtypes, like neuroendocrine, AR positive, double negatives, and
they also have a tendency to go to different sites.
So have you considered that maybe this is because of those subtypes,
the epigenetic profiles of the tumor cells, that the
microenvironment is different? Yeah.
Yeah. No, that's a really great question.
And now that we're at the Hutch,
as you know, that group
has actually a really big cohort of patients who've been
assessed in that way and classified into the
AR/neuroendocrine phenotypes.
And so that work is planned, and we're looking
forward to tap into that. But we don't have an answer at present for that question.
Thank you.
Akash, I thought maybe you might comment on
anti-tumor role of myeloid cells.
I was going to-
Yeah
... hope that you were here and pick your brain.
Yeah, that's a good segue, Tom, to the question I was just going to ask Larry.
So, Larry, as we previously published that cabozantinib
can actually reprogram neutrophils to an anti-tumor
subset, and that actually led to this clinical trial looking at
combining cabo and nivo. And as you also know, that cabo
had initially the interest came from all the clearance that we saw with
subsets of patients with bone metastases.
So I wonder if some of this is actually happening through reprogramming of
neutrophils in the bone. And we now have paired biopsies, which we
just completed the study for. We could actually look at this, and it'd be
great to talk more about how we might be able to collaborate to look at your
subset-
Yeah
... in our clinical trial samples.
That's absolutely terrific, and we'd love to collaborate with you.
I think one of the things that's really challenging as we
think about the myeloid compartment, whether it's the Tams or it's the
neutrophils, there are different populations of
the macrophages, and there are different populations of the neutrophils that may
have very different functions. We focused on
immunosuppression, but absolutely to your point,
and there's a literature in terms of
neutrophils with anti-tumor effect.
And I do think, with the results that you're seeing,
perhaps some of those could be that transition of these neutrophils into
that population in the bone. And so
I'm of the same thinking. So we'll
follow up. Yeah.
Sounds great. Thanks.
So I have two questions, comments, to try and bring the three talks
together. One is-- Can you-- Or you want to--
Yeah, just stay there. Okay. That's fine.
So the SPP1 positive macrophage subset,
do you have any
inkling whether those are tissue-resident macrophages in prostate cancer that get
in? Do you find them in normal prostate tissue,
SPP1 macrophages?
Yeah. No, that's a great question.
Your results are really
provocative.
We can see these SPP1
myeloid cells in "normal prostate."
But I think one of the challenges in our human data is what is
actually normal prostate versus not.
And
with our single-cell analysis, sometimes when we get
tissues that are like normal prostate, there's actually tumor cells
in them.
And so I think that's a challenging question to
disentangle with our human data. But I think with the approaches that
you've taken, it would actually be really interesting to get at
that.
Yeah. So I'm just wondering if that's going to be a generalizable principle
as we transition those findings to the human.
The other thing, so for Daniel, so we've done a lot of spatial
transcriptomics of immune cell interaction in mouse and
human tumors. Actually, more human than mouse.
But
we can find clusters of Bada3 dendritic cells in CD8 T
cells, and we can look at the transcriptional signature of the T cells.
This was published recently, and those
are the good T cells. They're activated by those dendritic cells.
But we can also find clusters
by Visium of T cells and M2-like
macrophages.
Mm-hmm.
And when we look at that T cell
transcriptional signature, they're not activated. Right?
So,
in different model systems, the
percentage of the M2-like clusters and the
dendritic cell clusters varies, and when there are more T cells
in these suppressive macrophage clusters, in those settings,
immunotherapy doesn't work. Checkpoint blockade doesn't work.
So I'm wondering, have you studied
suppressive macrophage clusters in any of your samples?
It's a really interesting question, Tom.
So we see all kinds of APCs present in clusters, so
it's the B cells, monocyte macrophages, and DCs.
And again,
not all of the cell states that they're in are equally
distributed.
So we see enrichment of specific cell states for all of those APC
cell types in clusters with T cells.
What their role is,
is something that we're currently pursuing.
Because you have a great assay to do this, right?
Can you count percentages of T cells interacting with
DCs versus macrophages? Which is, if you
can do single cell of the macrophage part, see which ones are suppressive
phenotypically-
Right
... right? And do those ratios predict checkpoint blockade efficacy?
For the DCs, we see this C1Q high,
no, not for the monocyte macrophage.
We see this C1Q high lipid-associated-
Yeah
... macrophage. We don't know exactly yet
what the function is in conjugation with the T cell.
Yeah, that's super interesting, I think.
I didn't have time to talk about it.
We also see CD4 T cells in clusters.
Are they suppressive? Are they supportive? Are they killers? We don't know.
We're currently looking at that.
Oh, and then-
And there's many biological questions that remain to be discovered, and I think
it's a nice platform.
And then the coup de gras, so have you seen
dendritic cell CD8 FoxP3 Treg
clusters?
That's exactly what we're looking at.
Yeah. It's so interesting. It's a powerful tool.
And-
Next
... yeah, the GPNMB knockout macrophages, by the way, they
lose the lipid
phenotype-
Yeah
... by staining, right?
So that's part of the immune suppressive program.
Any other questions from the group?
We'll call it a wrap then. Thanks for sticking around.
Thank you.